pourquoi la russie a attaqué le cren
parce que moi j'ai eu 50 textos dormi
deux potes qui disaient qu'est ce qui se
passe pour pour la russie attaqué le
crédit alors ces deux équipes de foot
qui se partagent le même ballon et la
russie ne souhaitait pas que les états
unis gagne le match et donc ils sont
intervenus avant c'est un conflit qui a
commencé une vingtaine d'années d'accord
autour de la question de savoir si
l'ukraine allaient être plutôt côté
américain ou plutôt côté russe d'accord
c'est donc qu'il ya eu cet affrontement
cette tentation de faire entrer
l'ukraine dans l'otan et poutine
estimant qu'il y avait un risque que
l'ukraine entre dans l'otan donc côté
américain a fait une intervention pour
s'assurer le gain du pays donc voilà
c'est ça la fait un voile à faire pour
pour être clair c'est que oui bien sûr
baptismaux il explique bien c'est pour
ça qu'il est là il va prendre un mec qui
est à dire n'importe quoi non plus non
mais c'est c'est fou parce que pourquoi
il a fait il l'a fait maintenant juste
parce qu'il veut vraiment c'était
c'était le dernier et voilà c'était
maintenant qu'il fallait le faire selon
moi j'entends maintenant j'attends ça
depuis deux ans ça fait jouer ça fait
deux trois ans on lille vont intervenir
en personne n'y croyait mais c'est
servir non et c'est pas possible pas il
peut pas intervenir on avait les photos
avec des chars avec il ya même des des
éléments qui fut fait mais on n'y
croyait pas on pensait pas que ça puisse
être possible jean baptiste moi je vous
lis ça fait deux trois ans que il ya
plein de gens qui me disent de toutes
les façons tu vas voir dont très peu de
temps est vraiment une guerre mondiale à
cause de la russie parce que la russie
va attaquer l'ukraine c'est ce qu'on
vous disait aussi ou pas c'est ce que
tout le monde disait saint on est on est
dans une forme de guerre mondiale entre
etats-unis et russie en ukraine le
risque c'est que le conflit se déplace
vers le nord de l'europe donc pologne
pays baltes c'est un pays baltes
craignent aussi une invasion et puis il
faudra voir aussi ce qui va se passer en
la vie peut-être russie chine sibérie
éventuellement donc on est au début de
quelque chose dont on ne peut pas encore
prévoir les conséquences alors on dit
aussi que vladimir poutine a toujours
regretté la perte des territoires
soviétique après la chute de l'urss avec
eux pour lui voilà c'est ça fait partie
de ces ça c'est à dire 30 ans voilà
c'est ça d'ailleurs on allait commémorer
l'indépendance des pays bas un moment
quand même l'indépendance ils sont
envahis par la russie et effectivement
il y avait cette nostalgie de l'urss et
d'ailleurs il a dit c'est une la plus
grande catastrophe géopolitique du 20e
siècle donc à la nostalgie de l'urss et
aussi la nostalgie du fait que la lui n
c'est le berceau de la russie c'était là
la russie de kiev la route de kiev et
donc quelle idée aussi de recréer un
territoire historique qui on va très
bien sûr sur vos cartes et et l'ukraine
c'est aussi une zone avec l'accès à la
mer noire est également une à carrefour
à la fois du blé et du gaz donc pour la
russie c'est une zone c'est à la fois
sentimentale et économiquement important
d'accord pourquoi au département de
parler de la région de parler du dombass
voilà il disait que il n'irait pas plus
loin pourquoi qu'est ce qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui en basse alors c'est une
basse et une région où il y avait des
matches de foot vrai pendant l'euro de
l'ukraine d'accord voilà donc ya
quelques années il y avait les équipes
d'europe qui était là en train de jouer
au foot et aujourd'hui la région et sous
les bombes depuis 2014 et donc ça fait
huit ans de guerre d'une région qui est
plutôt russophone qui est plus attaché à
la russie que le reste de l'ukraine et
donc qui a fait sécession en 2014 on
voit très bien c'est votre carte avec
les deux région de lougansk est et
donetsk et qui donc de cul 2014 sont des
république autonome et avec une guerre
avec le reste de l'ukraine et la russie
est intervenu estimant qu'elle était
menacée afin de les protéger d'accord
aujourd'hui on en est où deux depuis ce
matin alors depuis ce matin là ça évolue
sans arrêt alors si aujourd'hui on a
appris que tchernobyl avait été pris par
la russie donc qu'ils vont réparer la
centrale on va voir et la remettre en
place et puis il ya également la
capitale kiev l'armée russe est pas très
loin de kiev il ya un aéroport militaire
qui a été pris ça a été extrêmement
rapide en une journée ils contrôlent les
principaux points de l'ukraine et ils
ont bombardé qu'on fait des
bombardements sont les principales
villes est ce que est ce que les
principaux chefs d'états comme dubaï
donne emmanuel macron qui a vu 21 heures
poutine ya quelques jours est ce qu'il
le savait que cette nuit la russie à
l'attaqué l'ukraine ou pas du tout abbas
il le savait il aurait peut-être fait
autrui sont intervenus c'est qu'il s'en
doutait pas du tout ils savaient pas
qu'il ait pas des signes c'est pas ça va
se passer c'est teminé pas cher qu'il ya
le précédent de choses et où
d'acquisition me oui les états le
magnétisme hills etats-unis 2 savez vous
voyez kiev
l'ouest et de l'est non le s2 à
la frontière avec la pologne les etats
unis ont transféré l'ambassade leur
ambassade à lui à et hier ils ont
transféré de l'oif en pologne donc tout
ça donc voyez ça c'est une info
incroyable ait ça veut dire donc que les
états unis étaient au courant si les
états unis étaient au courant on peut
penser qu'il l'a il manuel macron ça
cette info la villa noailles au lavoir
il là il est temps que il a été demandé
aux français de quitter l'ukraine incite
à leurs ressortissants américains donc
est ce qu'ils ont essayé une dernière
fois de parler à vladimir poutine ou pas
du tout que ce soit les américains les
français entendent également parlé mais
c'est pas ça qui aboutit forcément des
résultats mais il leur dit quoi vladimir
poutine que c'est intéressant de savoir
on se pose tous la question on se dit
quand on lui dit voilà il ya joe biden
qui vous appelle il ya ma emmanuel
macron et angela merkel yahia de hier et
qui se disent qu'il est le rémois ceux
des menaces en disant si vous intervenez
on va en bon va vous couper l'accès au
système bancaire d'accord mais plus de
faire de commerce international ou alors
on va couper des aides qui vous sont
apportées au niveau avec les autres donc
yaya décès comme un enfant on y va si tu
mets la main dans le pot de bonbons tu
auras une sanction et puis il ya des
temps forts qui devint j'ai peur de la
baf donc j'interviens pas et puis est ce
qu'ils se disent là-bas va pas faire
très mal dont je préfère prendre les
bonbons mais est-ce que vous pensez que
la bave offerman elle va on va voir mais
le c'est un double jeu par exemple la
moitié du gaz allemand vient de russie
ouais donc aussi il ya une serrure du
gaz russe serait ce que parce que les
écolos en allemagne où on levait la
plupart des centrales nucléaires
exactement dont aujourd'hui google
allemagne aujourd'hui c'est brive on est
en excès des traitements tribu t elle
sont extrêmement tributaire de la russie
comment ils font l'allemagne ils
enlèvent allemands ont dit qu'il leur a
remis ne pouvait pas intervenir donc il
y a plus d'armée allemandes
opérationnelles ils sont très ennuyés
parce que ils sont tellement dépendants
au gaz russe que tant qu'ils n'ont pas
des désaxés autres ils sont empêtrés ils
ne pourront pas réellement intervenir
quelque chose et alors l'allemagne
l'allemagne kehl et les sanctions
quelles sont les sanctions ne peut
prendre l'allemagne contre la russie
alors par exemple ils ont repoussé
l'ouverture du gazoduc nord stream 2
c'est le gars de l'équipe a dans la
baltique d'accord doit ouvrir
normalement au mois de juin ils vont
liban l'eau c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment c'est anecdotique
alors après vous avez partie économique
mais là aussi la dépendance est toujours
à deux tiers que si on fait des tensions
contre la russie ça sanctionne aussi une
entreprise européenne prenez total total
est installée en russie ça si tu ne peux
plus faire d'acte et économique en
russie ça fonctionne et la russie est
totale ouais leroy merlin entreprises
françaises est assez présente également
en russie le groupe auchan de manière
générale donc vous avez beaucoup de
français qui travaillent à moscou ou à
saint-pétersbourg et beaucoup
d'entreprises françaises qui font des
activités à saint-pétersbourg et à
moscou donc les toute sanction contre la
russie est tout aussi une forme de
sanction contre la france alors on a vu
que la chine est un des seuls pays qui
ne s'est pas prononcée contre la russie
c'est vrai que c'est ça qui nous fait
flipper la chine la russie est ce que
vous pensez que les insectes le
gouvernement chinois est au courant de
ce qu'ils allaient faire véritablement
il est même possible que poutine et
reculer la tacc après les jeux
olympiques
là encore ah oui oui en 2014 date à qui
a été fait pendant les jo là ils se sont
dit bon on va laisser les jo de pékin se
faire convenablement je vais pas faire
une une crasse à mon ami chinois et ils
attaquent quelques jours après la fin de
juin